Great movies are like a conversation.
Filmmakers are communicating with the audience,
sure—but they're also communicating with
each other...or sometimes themselves.
Often, directors just can't help themselves,
and let everyone eavesdrop on their cinematic
conversations.
Here are hidden Easter eggs that reference
other movies.
Toy Story
While trapped at Sid's house, Buzz Lightyear
experiences a small existential crisis and
starts wandering.
Does that carpet seem familiar?
That's because it was lifted from the Overlook
Hotel in The Shining.
While we appreciate the nod to a Stanley Kubrick
classic, we're happy Pixar stopped short of
showing us creepy twins or elevators full
of blood.
Zootopia
Toward the end of Zootopia, Duke Weaselton
is selling bootleg DVDs on the street.
In addition to the fact that Duke Weaselton’s
name is a reference to Frozen's Duke of Weselton...
...the DVDs he's selling are animal versions
of Disney films like Big Hero 6, Tangled,
Wreck-It Ralph, and more.
Does anyone else really want to actually see
these movies?
Considering Pig Hero 6 is billed as "the best
animated movie on this DVD," it's gotta be
good, right?
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
Captain America: The Winter Soldier boasts
some super-spy action featuring Nick Fury,
played by Samuel L. Jackson.
He's probably still most famous for his role
in Pulp Fiction as Jules Winnfield.
Jules quoted a Bible verse right before gunning
down a man .
"Ezekiel 25:17?
The path of the righteous man is beset on
all sides by the inequities of the selfish,
and the tyranny of evil men."
Part of that same quote is on Fury's headstone
after he’s presumed dead.
Rango
In this Johnny Depp film, Rango gets into
some trouble and tumbles around on the highway
in the desert.
Before he gets to safety, Rango ends up pancaked
on the windshield of a Cadillac Eldorado...being
driven by the characters from Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas, starring Johnny Depp.
The kids must’ve gotten a kick out of this,
because children just love Hunter S. Thompson.
Coming to America
Coming to America stars Eddie Murphy as a
young African prince intent on experiencing
what America has to offer.
During his travels, he encounters some down-on-their-luck
brothers who could use a buck or two.
These bums just happen to be the Duke Brothers,
the antagonists from Murphy's earlier hit,
Trading Places.
After going broke in the previous movie, it's
nice to see Prince Akeem lending a hand.
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
In Tim Burton's Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory, we find out that Charlie's dad makes
very little money screwing on the caps of
Smilex toothpaste at a factory.
But did you realize that we've heard of Smilex
before?
Way back in Tim Burton's Batman from 1989:
"New and improved Joker products!
With a new secret ingredient, Smilex!"
The Polar Express
Robert Zemeckis directed The Polar Express,
a CGI Christmas movie starring Tom Hanks.
He also directed the Back to the Future series,
featuring one of the most iconic time machines
ever: the DeLorean.
Remember what makes the DeLorean work?
That's right, the Flux Capacitor.
Well, it turns out that’s how the Polar
Express gets to the North Pole so fast.
Predator 2
While watching Predator 2, you can spot a
skull in the trophy room that looks pretty
familiar.
In case you were wondering, yes, it does belong
to a Xenomorph from the Alien movies—and
its presence is only natural because Aliens
and Predators live in a shared universe.
And it's always hunting season for the Predators.
Still, they better hope they never try to
hunt rabbits.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Easter egg was the biggest surprise to you.